[موسيقى]
عام طبعا الواحد طبعا هذا مو اول مؤتمر
انا احضره وحضرت مؤتمرات وكثير من الاحيان
انا اكون محضر لشيء واطلع على المسرح
واقول شيء ثاني عام تقريبا
1988 انا شفت زميلي ابو محمد سعيد
الثنيان
و دخل وصدفه اح انا كنت قاعد اشتغل على
الحاسوب
حقي فانا عندي مشكله المشكله كيف ان لما
اركز اللي حواليني ما اشعر فيه وحدث ان
ابو
محمد الش حقه اشتعلت فيه النار وانا ما
ادري صارت الدنيا
خبصه اسعاف
واصوات زوجتي موجوده هنا انا قادر اشوفها
انا صارلي ساعتين ادورها بس ما انا قادر
احدد قالت قوم شوف شش
صاير تقول الدنيا خبصه فرحت اطالع للدنيا
ا النار واصل ل عنان السماء والدنيا خبصه
فوق تحت طبعا الفرق بينه وبين شقه ابو
محمد شارع
واحد طبعا كنا حديثي الزواج من ذاك الوقت
شعرت ان انا بحاجه الى الانسانه هذه لانها
تكملني لانه ربما بسبب نوعيه التركيز اللي
اسويه زين انسى حالي فدائما محتاج فهي ضحت
بكل شيء بكل شيء طبعا انا مو راضي عن نفسي
انا مو راضي عن نفسي واذا في اي نجاح فهو
نجاح مضعف
بتضحياتها
ومحاولاتي في ان انا اوصل شيء الى
الناس عموما انا ابغى نسوي تمرين صغير قبل
ما نبدي المحاضره وهو كل انسان فينا وكل
واحد ياخذ يد اليمين ويلمس فيها يد اليسار
ماشوف حد
سوى المهم الشي اللي ابغاه اوصله لكم ان
انت ككيان ومتعود الكل يشوفك كيان لك اسم
لك لش اسم ش اللي يصير ان الذرات الم
موجوده عندنا في يد
اليمين جايه من مكان مختلف من الكون عن
الذرات الم موجوده في اليد
اليسار بعض الذرات الل فينا عمرها 14
مليار
سنه احتمال اللي في اليد اليمين جات من
شمس عمرها خلينا نقول 10 مليار سنه والد
اليسار جات من شمس
عمرها 5 مليار سنه تبعد يمكن ملايين
السنين الضوئيه عموما انا طولت في
المقدمه ولكن خلينا ناخذ تاريخ الكون
الكون الكل متفق انه تقريبا 14 مليار
سنه احنا نطور في كجنين والجنين يتطور من
جزء او من من طور الى اخر الكون نفس الشيء
الكون
هذا مر باطوار وهي موجوده على
الشاشه لكن في اول طور في الكون مر بالطور
يسموه طور الجسيمات الجسيمات الصغيره جدا
ما في اي شيء ولا حتى
ذرات وبعد الذرا بعد الجسيمات هذه تكونت
اللي يسموها
المجرات وفي
المجرات تولدت الشموس ومن الشموس اتت
الكواكب وعلى الكواكب صار في تفاعلات
كيميائيه والتفاعلات الكيميائيه ادت الى
الحياه والحياه ادت الى حضارات والحضارات
عندها هم المستقبل وتحدي
المستقبل طبعا ش صار بعد بعيد الانفجار
نقول ليش لان هذا جزء 10 اس سالب 45 من
الثانيه
يعني يعني جدا جدا جدا
ضئيل تكونت ماده وماده
مضاده لكل مليار
وواد ماده تكونت مليار وواحد ماده مليار
ماده
مضاده ايش اللي يصير ش يعني ماده وماده
مضاده الماده تعني ان انا اجيب هذه الماده
واجيب الماده المضاده اقربهم من بعض
اثنينهم اثنينهم يختفون لكن ما يختفون
هباء منصوره تتكون من خلال اختفائهم طاقه
هي التي نحتاجها لبناء
الذرات يعني بدون الطاقه هذه ما ممكن
تتكون ذرات وفي خلال هذه الفتره البسيطه
بعد
الانفجار تكونت الطاقه المطلوبه لتكوين
الذرات انا ابغاكم تركزون على حاجتين
مهمتين
هي هي هذه الماده والماده المضاده التي
ساهمت في تكوين الذرات وفي تكويننا احنا
اصلا الشيء الثاني البرت اينشتاين كان فكر
قبل طبعا ما هبل ادون هبل يعرف ان الكون
قاعد يتمدد كان البرت اينشتاين يتوقع ان
الكون ما يتوسع فهو كان همه يشوف حاجه
اسمها الثابت الكوني كوزمولوجي كونستن
وبغى يشوف كثافه الماده في المتر المكعب
كم وسوى حسابات وطلع بحساب وطبعا حساب
تقريبا
قريب طبعا تكلمنا عن المكان الثابت كوني
هذا اللي اكتشفوه وحسبوه العلماء وفي
الوقت الراهن يقوللك هو احنا عشان نقرب
الصوره خلنا يكون عندنا متر مربع كم حجمه
هذا من المتر مربع حجمه ع اس سالب
250 يعني علشان نقرب لكم الصوره تخيلوا
حجم الكره الارضيه الثابت الكوني عباره عن
حبه رمل حبه بالنسبه الىى حجم الكره
الارضيه خلينا نقول حبتين اساس ابغى ابين
فكره لو صارت الحبتين ثلاث حبات الكون ما
ممكن يتكون ينكمش على
بعضها ولو صار حبه بدون حبتين الكون
يتبعثر في الكون يتبعثر ولا ممكن يتكون اي
شيء فعلينا نحسب الدقه دقه الماده والماده
المضاده وهذا الثابت الكوني اللي يفترض
انه يكون محسوب لان به الدقه هذه صعب انه
يجي كذا صدفه
عموما في الكون تكونت ذرات بدائيه بسبب شش
قلنا احنا تتذكرون ليش كيف تكون الذرات
بسبب الماده والماده المضاده فتكون
الذرات الذرات اللي تكونت ذرات بدائيه
اللي هي ذرات الهيدروجين وذرات الهيليوم
طبعا ذرات الهيدروجين تقريبا لكل عشر ذرات
هيدروجين كونت ذره في
اليوم
طبعا الصوره اللي قدامكم ما نبغى نناقش
فيها كثير ولكن
هي تصورات الطاقه بعد الانفجار على طول
والطاقه اليوم علماء الفيزياء يعتبرون كل
شيء طاقه انا وانت طاقه ما في شيء ماده
الماده هذه مجرد شعور لا اكثر فهي
طاقه فعموما لو نلاحظ ان الطاقه تتغير
نسبتها تتغير من اول الى
الان احنا قلنا اذا تتذكرون ان بعد
الجسيمات وبعد المجرات تكونت
شموس هذه الشمس احدى الشموس هذه تقريبا
شمس
ضخمه كم تتوقعون اكبر من شمسنا هذه احد
عنده اي
فكره
كم
مليار يعني
شمسنا جزء من مليار من هذه الشموس ايش
مهمه هذه الشموس هذه الشموس تقعد تصنع
ذرات هي فرن لصناعه
الذرات طبعا هي لا تصنع كل الذرات تصنع
ذرات بدائيه وخفيفه الى ان
تقف تقف عند ايش
الحديد هذا الحديد احنا كلنا نعرف انه في
باس شديد نكسر فيه ونصنع فيه وحضارتنا
اعتمدت على الحديد ففيه
باس وفي العلماء يقولون ان الحديد هذا
انزل من السماء لان احنا ما ممكن شمسنا
تكون حديد فلا بد ان نج من السماء ف تم
نزول الحديد من الفضاء الى الارض
لكن حديد الباس الشديد اللي فيه فعلا هو
ان هذا الحديد مثل الفيروس بالنسبه للشمس
بس يدخل في الشمس تبدلي تكون الشمس الحديد
تقعد تمرض تكون حديد زياده وتمرض
اكثر الى
ان الحديد يتمكن من الشمس ويقضي عليها
شايفين الشمس هذه اللي حجمها مليار مره
هذه تبلع شموس وتبلع كواكب و عايشه قدامها
الا
الحديد يخليها تموت تنفجر ويصير انفجار
عظيم يسمونه سوبر
نوفا هذا
الانفجار يعطينا الطاقه اللازمه علشان
نكون الذرات الثقيله ف لو لولا يعني هذا
الانفجار ما في ذرات ثقيله احنا نعتمد على
كثير من
الذرات طبعا هذا الجدول الدوري لو تلاحظ
ان الحديد هو عباره عن العنصر رقم 26
كل العناصر الثقيله اتت بسبب
الانفجار
عموما هذا رجل اسمه جيمز بيلي عالم طبعا
متخصص فقط كيف الحديد ياثر على الشمس وليش
طبعا المجال ما يسمح ان احنا
نذكر تتذكرون من اللي حطيناه هذا الرسمه
الاولى ان الكون عمر 14 مليار زي ما مرينا
بال بالتفاعلات الكيميائيه على الكواكب
لما صارت تفاعلات كيميائيه مركبات او
جزيئات بسيطه الى ان وصلنا الى حاجه مهمه
وهي نسميها الحمض
الاميني الحمض الاميني هو مركب كيميائي
لكن هذا الحمض الاميني ضروري لتكوين
البروتينات
البروتينات اللي في جسمنا وفي اي شيء هي
تاتي من الحمض الاميني وميزه الحمض
الاميني
انه ممكن يسبب لنا سلسله طويله تقريبا هل
احد عنده خبر كم يوصل طول حمض اميني
معين تقريبا
مليار مليار حمض اميني يتصلون مع بعض على
اساس تكون ايش عندنا احنا اللي نسميه
الحمض النووي او دي ان ايه فهذا تقريبا
حجمه مليار حمض
اميني طبعا نجي ل البروتينات شريط ايش
اللي يعطيك الخصائص انت او انت ش اللي
يخليك ذكر انثى اسف ذكر
وانثى ايش اللي يصير اللي يصير ان تعطينا
البروتينات شايفين انتم كل بروتين عباره
عن ثلاثه
حروف ف شايفين احمر اصفر اخضر
ازرق عندنا الانسان عنده تقريبا زي ما
قلنا مليار حمض اميني فتخيل انت
تجي وتسوي لها مليار تشكيله فتعطيك عدد
مهول من الناس والاشكال فهذا اللي يعطيك
شخصيتك انت ويخليك انسان مختلف طبعا
البروتينات ممكن تكون اعقد ولكن
البروتينات تتكون في الخليه الخليه هي
مصنع للبروتينات
فكل جسمنا احنا عباره عن بدايه خلايا تكون
بروتينات لو اخذنا مقطع عرضي الى الخليه
ايش نشوف فيها نشوف فيها جسم
ونواه النواه فيها حاجه مثل
الزراديه شايفين هذا بالازرق هذا اللي مثر
الزرادي يسمون كروموزوم والانسان لعدد
محيد محدد من الكروموزومات وفي كروموزومات
انثويه وكروم سومات ذكريه وعلى فكره كل
كروموزومات انثويه ماذا كروموزوم واحد
وصغير هو الذكري فالذكر يتحدى جنسه من
كروموزوم واحد عموما هذا لو اخذنا وفلنا
كشريط يطلع عندنا الشفره الوراثيه اللي في
حمض الدي ان ايه هذا موجود بالاخضر زي
السلم هذه عباره قلنا هي طبعا الاحماض
الامينيه والشغلات هذه والحروف وتتشابك مع
بعضها على اساس لا
تتفكك خلونا نرجع ال الانسان من جديد
وخلونا نتذكر الكلام اللي قلناه قلنا
ان اول ما ابتدي الكون في
ثابت كوني كون لنا المجرات لكن قبل على
اساس تكون مجرات لازم نكون ذرات ولازم في
ماده وماده مضاده الحين احنا نجي انا
انسان سوي كامل ايش اللي يصير كامل فيني
اعضاء او اجهزه معينه والاجهزه تجي فيها
اعضاء مثل المعده مثلا عندنا جهاز هضمي
وعندنا معده المعده يتكون تتكون من الياف
والالياف هذه تتكون من خلايا والخلايا
تتكون من جزيئات ومركبات والمركبات تتكون
من ذرات فذرات اللي تكونت فينا ايش السبب
الرئيسي حقها
تذكرون الثابت
الكوني والماده والماده المضاده طبعا جسم
الانسان متكون من ذرات هذه من ناحيه ماديه
طبعا مو من ناحيه فلسفيه فاكثر شيء فينا
الاكسجين وفينا هيدروجين وفينا كربون وهذا
شيء طبيعي وهذا خلق في الشموس لذلك الذرات
اللي في يدك اليمين ممكن تجي من شمس
والذرات اللي في يدك اليسار ممكن تجي من
شمس
اخرى طبعا في ناس العلماء علماء الفيزياء
وعلماء الكون مهووسون يعني يقول كيف
الانسان يتكون بالصدفه احنا خلنا نحسب
فجاب الثابت الكوني والماده والماده
المضاده فشاف ان نحتاج تقريبا الى عدد 10
اس 500 يعني او واح على 10 اس 500 وهذا
عدد جدا جدا جدا ضئيل على اساس بس نقرب
لكم احد يعرف هنا احد صارت صاعقه برقيه ما
اعتقد القطيف كله يمكن ما احد صارت صاعقه
برقيه ولكن احتماليه ان الانسان يصاب
بصاعقه برقيه 100 250 مره متتاليه هو فقط
يجيله البرق هذ وين ما يروح
وتصده اكثر من انه يخلق بالصدفه هذه
حسابات العلماء ما حسابات يعني انسان مؤمن
لا العلماء يقولون كذا موجود براين جرين
يناقش هذه القضيه مناقشه تامه هذا الرجال
سويت حساب وهذا الرجال هو اكثر شخص في
الدنيا
صارت صواعق سب مرات فقط سبع مرات وليست
متتاليه
عموما احنا نقول طبعا يبدون الوقت خلص
ولكن ما ممكن نخلق نظام من عشوائيه بدون
مدبر ولا بد من وجود مدبر ياخذ العشوائيه
هذه ويسويها نظام زي ما امهاتنا نجي نعفس
الغرفه حقنا ونجي يوم الثاني ما نشوف هلا
مرتبه ومنظمه وشكرا جزيلا و
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
inte